Angespannte Ruhe am Morgen nach den Angriffen
in der Nacht zu Donnerstag auf den Golan-Höhen.
Dabei ist der Konflikt an der syrisch-israelischen
Grenze zwischen Israel und dem Iran eskaliert.
Erstmals seit Beginn des Krieges im Nachbarland
griffen in der Nacht zu Donnerstag iranische
Revolutionsgarden nach israelischen Angaben
Armeeposten auf den Golan-Höhen an.
Die israelische Luftwaffe reagierte mit massiven
Vergeltungsangriffen auf syrische Militäreinrichtungen
und iranische Stellungen in dem Nachbarland.
Nach israelischen Armeeangaben feuerten Einheiten
der iranischen Revolutionsgarden insgesamt
rund 20 Raketen auf israelische Armeeposten
entlang der Grenze ab.
In Teilen Nordisraels wurde Raketenalarm ausgelöst.
Die israelischen Vergeltungsangriffe zählten
zu den schwersten seit Ausbruch des Krieges
im Nachbarland 2011.
Bewohner berichteten unter anderem von starken
Explosionen nahe der Hauptstadt Damaskus.
Syrische Medien berichteten, die Luftabwehr
habe Raketen unter anderem über Damaskus
und Homs abgefangen.